Herbie good morning thanks for joining
us come on sorry about that yeah that
was kinda quite a quite an evening when
ole miss is up and a half time now I did
think the touchdown at the end of the
first half was huge for Florida State
but yeah what did you think going into
halftime of that game well I think and I
think we talked about on the air just
because of the history of Florida State
they they have a tendency to get in at
halftime and come out and look like a
completely different team if you
remember the 14-team that was kind of
their mo and you didn't know where the
redshirt freshman and they could be that
kind of team until you saw it but I just
really know that the jimbo fisher
probably just as well as anybody he and
nick saban and that second half and look
what shocked me was how much better the
line play knew how much better the
defense played it was it was a
collective effort it was like watching
two different teams best win or the
weekend was who ah I'll go up the board
I mean Houston is I think what everybody
would say because of the magnitude of
the wind beating a top-five opponent but
I was really impressed with Wisconsin
most people are talking about what's
wrong with ls years and Les Miles be
fired I walked away from watching every
player that game st. King and Wisconsin
looks really athletic on defense and
really motivated I thought Paul Chris
did a great job getting his team ready
considering you know what you kind of
were waiting for what you thought you
knew about Wisconsin we kind of knew
Houston was good I didn't have any idea
that Wisconsin was capable of doing that
so that was probably the one that really
jumped out at me but Oklahoma game
against houston and texas notre dame
those are obviously other ones as well
worst loss was who well and it had to be
Oklahoma I know that if you're in the
SEC you would say LSU but Oklahoma all
we heard about is their preseason top
five ranking and seems like every time
their top five ranking they just have a
terrible year and
you know they went out and knew that
Houston with a great football team and
and just got out hustled and outplayed
and it was really it was really tough
loss for them and remember they do have
a high 0 state in two weeks kind of a
mulligan to try to kind of salvage their
season but that was a I was a tough loss
for a year is it a new trend where these
coaches athletic directors are going to
schedule tougher opponents we saw this
with quite a few teams but is this an
anomaly or is this you know the future
great question and we're going to have
to wait to see how the committee of 12
react to this opening weekend at the end
of the year I've made a point that a
team like Baylor for example who's kind
of summing their nose when before all
their off-the-field issues they were top
five kind of team it would play
northwestern state and Sam Houston State
and smu in their non-conference and they
would say our brows would publicly say
you know if we beat Oklahoma we beat tcu
we beat Texas and rest of our conference
we dare you to keep us out for the top
four if we win the big 12 12 feet and
that's that they would disable out and
play a bunch of cupcakes meanwhile other
teams are challenging themselves in a
non-conference and Baylor would be ahead
of them in the rankings in November and
until they lose a game and so another
name for example with no name plays a
game like they're willing to play Texas
in that kind of setting can they get to
the end of the year and if they're 11 in
one and their one loss of that over time
lost in austen and there's an undefeated
team that didn't play anybody their
non-conference me personally I would
have a one-loss notre dame ahead of an
undefeated team that didn't play a
ranked team in a non-conference for me
how the committee reacts will dictate
how head coaches and athletic directors
move into the future and schedule the
type of games that they schedule because
right now this weekend is definitely a
reaction to the committee saying
publicly that they're going to pay
attention to non-conference scheduling
now let's see if they if they back that
up with how they ranked teams at the end
of the year for curb street from the
mothership
joining a stamp a trade show is it a
foregone conclusion when this contract
is up that we're going to go from four
teams to eight teams or would it be even
more than eight teams in a playoff I
think if we if we move it's going to be
28 and I think I think it's probably
inevitable because as you know money
drives this whole thing and at some
point somebody's going to say you know
it'd be really nice if we barely opened
it up two more teams and get more teams
a chance I'd like for I think it still
gives us that urgency of this opening
weekend I mean this is an explosion to
the season for college football now we
have NFL coming in this week but what a
way for college football to just
dominate the weekend from thursday to
monday cuz because we had unprecedented
matchup yes and i think was having for
you know if you're in Oklahoma fan or an
LSU fan you're not or Notre Dame can
you're not out of it at this point but
man you're on the outside looking in and
I think college football enjoys the
regular season and urgency and mattering
every week you literally single and edge
of your seat for the whole season and
I'm a pirate in itself and to and you
start to feel that way you get to like
week 12 or 13 post college football you
feel that every week and if you go to
eight I still think you probably would
feel it I don't think you're ever going
to get to 16 or anything like that I
think if you were rewarded with a
tougher schedule I'd be fine with going
to eight if I if I was insured of having
great regular season matchups instead of
these you know cupcakes like Baylor I
had been then I I would not be for that
but if I'm going to reward you by
playing a tough schedule and you might
have two losses and you somehow get in
that 18 playoff I'd be fine with that I
do like the urgency of 4 i'm right there
with you on that we're talking what what
what one thing then is it that's a great
point I just want to add to that that
when i watch the committee my concern is
there's still that old ap voting result
coaches poll voting that if you're
undefeated it's almost like Lee Corso he
says next to me and he'll debate you
know what games which I you know
11 well I was undefeated so I gotta be
ranked ahead of the team for loss and I
said why David Beaton a ranked team Oh
like what why would you say they have to
and his answer is that i'ma feed it so
it's almost this old-school mentality of
if you're undefeated you have to be
ahead and I agree on the team with one
or two losses it makes no sense as we
saw Stanford plate Iowan the rose bowl
with two losses and because i was under
the end that one lost in some state were
they better in Stanford because they
only had that one loss obviously now
USC's loss ah we keep we keep waiting
for them to come back because it's good
for college football when USC is yeah in
the mix but I are they further away than
we think or it was that just Alabama is
that good and caught him at the right
time and humbled I forgot that when you
said maybe the worst loss of the weekend
because I expected that first quarter
was competitive yeah I thought we'd have
a competitive game I thought UFC shut it
down that was the thing that really
disappointed me was I don't know if they
they looked across the line about the
third quarter and said I had I've met
enough miss alabama defensive line and
offensive line huh I'm ready to go but I
thought the jamari bluffin kicking good
player down on the field there's some
persons character issues now he's
suspended for half of game against you
talk today I would have considered
suspending him for the rest of the year
they need to change the culture at USC
this is not a one game thing since Pete
left this has been going on with Lane
and Sark and now to start with play help
if your clay Helton you gotta draw a
line in the sand and say guys no more
annex I don't care if we lose every game
we're not playing like that I'm taking
notes on who played hard who quit and if
you quit on me you're not playing next
week like he's got to do something
drastic it's changed the culture of USC
because you're right college football
better when that bland is winning and
they matter and and you want get excited
go to the Coliseum and at that there's
some big issues right now on that roster
and he's gonna have to do something to
shake it up because that was a
combination of alabama's really good and
USC has a lot of work to do I'll leave
you with this if I told you a year ago
Carson Wentz and dak Prescott would
start week one of the NFL season the
following year what would you said no
way I I would not have thought that that
had a chance of happening especially how
can you sit here in the 2015 season and
say no what to go to state as much as we
love them they're starting quarterback
or their quarterback Carson Wentz is
going to be started in the NFL Week
wanna it's impossible to predict that
that Prescott if you had gone to the
right situation because of how powerful
he is it's just a matter would he be
able to grasp everything that it takes
to be a quarterback reading coverage
making the throws just like any young
rookie steps into that spot it's tough
to do to making that jump but boy I
think if he takes off he could become
another really really special
quarterback if you watch him throw you
watching move around presence in the
pocket in the college game reading
coverages and now he's got all those
tools around him to work with he's
probably the one guy I'm most excited to
watch this weekend of the rookie class
based on what he's capable of doing and
what he has the work with in that game
with the house did you try out for an
NFL team I you know I was one of those
guys did this is hard to explain because
in the back of the 90s I have to free
agent opportunities didn't get drafted
didn't have the passion the way I did
for college we didn't want to be a kid
that bounced around from arena football
and the world league at that time this
was ready to kind of move on I didn't
want to be a guy that was kind of
embarrassing for guys because it's NFL
wasn't in your future to kind of move on
with life and I just wanted to move on I
had no idea where I was headed I got
into local radio and and things kind of
really took off
in a year but I just did not want to
bounce around from really too worldly I
just felt like time to close that that
chapter and you kind of move on and you
did thank you do yeah hey thanks for
getting up and safe travels tell chris
we said hello and hopefully we'll talk
again thanks Herbie yeah you gotta buddy
anytime all right Kirk Herbstreit the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience